a spinal surgeon divorces his beauty
queen wife because she let a secret life
as a high-end hooker earning 700 000
so i'm just going to rip through this
real quick and then we'll go back to the
full screen and and jonathan will chop
it a little chop it up a little bit from
his perspective
uh but this spinal surgeon dr han joe
kim
settled his divorce from a former beauty
beauty queen named regina turner
court documents reviewed by new york
daily news a surgeon reportedly
discovered the ex-miss connecticut had
been engaging in sex work
this allegedly happened during sorry
before and during their marriage which
began in 2015
he claims turner received cash payments
from men totaling
six hundred and seventy five thousand
and thirty dollars in cash deposits
from 2015 to 2021. so that was that was
a little over a hundred thousand dollars
a year
she made hooking i guess um
according to reports in court documents
dr kim reportedly seeking to
void the marriage on the basis of fraud
uh this is her looking all
snacky on stage during her miss
connecticut appearance i guess i think
this is
2011 she won this uh title it's a beauty
pageant
and here she is doing you know the you
know the good old pose with the
kids bicycle putting training wheels on
saving you know saving the west
miss connecticut and here's dr
kim uh the spinal surgeon who was making
three million dollars a year in 2018
according to
uh this article um
you know what i know that uh jonathan
dove into it
quite deep um there's a lot to unpack
with this and this doesn't always make
the media
so rather than read the article and bore
you
with what the media has put together why
don't we give the floor
to our good friend jonathan noble the
lawyer
who's going to shed a little bit of
light on this from the legal perspective
from the legal mind
yeah thank you rich first of all as you
start to look at the facts as they're
presented to us and we don't know
everything because we weren't part of
this
uh marriage or relationship but he's 41
she's 32 so he's about nine years
uh her senior and in order to become a
surgeon you may or may not know it takes
many many years it's
you know college then medical school
then internship
residency probably did a sub-specialty
and spinal surgery
so he could have been in his mid-30s you
know when he was
no longer in school and uh looking
to get married and along comes a very
pretty woman
who must have cast a spell over him for
lack of a better term
and they they married and he gave her a
great life
but what he obviously didn't know was
her secret life where
she was earning substantial amount of
money sleeping with other guys
or educating other guys desires however
you want to frame it
so now if you really think about it guys
got to be pretty smart
at least book smart to get all those
credentials and to be a spine surgeon
i think that the process to be to get
into a surgical residency
it's like a pyramid it's very difficult
uh there are other specialties that are
much easier but surgery is hard and
spine surgery
must be extremely difficult so he's
extremely
book smart but even the smartest
guy can get captivated if he has
one itis or he has uh
blinders on or he's just not watching
out what's going on
so this is a tale it's like a learning
moment a teaching moment where
even someone like that who should have
all of his wits about him
is married to someone uh you know that
bond under state law
and he didn't know for five years now i
think there was one picture that you may
have shown that was taken in 2011.
so they got married in december of 2012
uh
2015 yeah right and then he found out
about this in december of 2020
and that's some those are important
dates uh
so based on what i've been able to
discern
uh about the procedure in this case he
filed for an annulment
uh versus divorce what is that what is
that versus a divorce so they don't
okay so an annulment basically voids the
marriage and in most jurisdictions
there's void marriages which mean as a
matter of law
the marriage is is non-existent
what what would create avoid marriage
well if you marry
someone who isn't yet divorced from
their former spouse and they didn't tell
you that
because they couldn't find their former
spouse that's one
uh scenario that could create a void
marriage or
if the p if you're 16 years old and you
marry another 16 year old
uh and then you turn 18 your age of
majority and then you can go to the
court and say i want to know this
because i didn't know what i was doing
uh that could void a marriage um
there's another quirky area of the law
where you're not
enough degrees of khansanga beauty
is uh the term where the blood
relationship between you and the person
that you're married
isn't long enough like you marry your
first cousin or something
that would void a marriage so there's
all these quirky ways that you can get
out of it
but then there's voidable marriages uh
whereby
you marry someone based on duress or
fraud which i'm sure he alleged in this
and
if you can prove that you
were lied to to the degree that he was
there's a good chance you could have
your marriage voided uh or another did
you ever hear this story jonathan
started interrupt but there was
one that i was thinking of as you were
talking about these
annulments with a chinese man that sued
his wife for being ugly because she
misrepresented her appearance to him and
they ended up having what he called
ugly children apparently did you ever
hear this story no
wow and did he win i mean uh you could
people sue for the craziest reasons
i wonder if your wins says wins 120 000.
like you'd have to dig through some of
the records on this one to make sure
that it's confirmed but this was a story
that popped out a few years ago
well here it is it's uh 2012. wow
i don't know where that's located but
i'd love to read the statute that he
sued under
you know to try to get relief because he
married someone ugly like
didn't he see her walking out of the
shower didn't you see her
this is like after the plastic surgery
like she had her entire face
reconstructed completely
and then they had children together and
he wasn't pleased with the results so he
found out she had plastic surgery
and tried to sewer for it you know what
i'd be shaking my head if i were the
judge on that one
but uh one one point i want to make on
this other case with the surgeon
yeah if you're a victim of uh fraud or a
duress
you have to take action immediately you
can't continue to cohabitate with this
person
and then ask the court to annul your
marriage so
it seems to me like he saw some texts
that were really raunchy on her phone in
december of 2020 then filed to a null
is there a limitation period on those
sorts of actions when it comes to
annulling marriage because my
understanding was like you know you can
annul it if you were
drunk you went to vegas you got married
and you're like oh that was a bad idea
and four weeks later that you can annul
it but is there like a
limitation period that says that you
can't do anything after two years five
years or anything like that
you'd have to read the statute in each
jurisdiction like every state every
province has their own
uh marriage and divorce statutes i'm
just looking quickly here
uh you don't want to let too much time
lapse uh
especially if it's a claim of fraud or
duress
uh the way the statute reads at least in
pennsylvania uh there has been no
subsequent voluntary cohabitation
after knowledge of the fraud or release
of the fraud
duress or coercion uh so you're not
going to be able to plead
that this person lied to me so he took
action right away
i'm assuming that the new york statute's
similar where you just can't
continually cohabitate and then just one
day wake up and say
you know you lied to me um and if you
look at the totality of the
circumstances in his case
she lied to him about where this money
was coming from she was building an app
uh that in and of itself may not have
tipped the scales in his favor
she lied about her education um i don't
know man that was never graduated high
school right she said she had three
years of college but
he wasn't marrying her because of her
college degree or lack thereof
she was very pretty i mean there's no
way around it um
so he took action right away and that's
how you protect your rights whether it's
child
custody or or duress or
or you know fraudulent marriage but what
does that do if he got an annulment
it gave his attorney great leverage why
because
if your marriage is a null you don't
have to go through the divorce machine
so he's able to settle everything oh so
you don't deal with child support
alimony
marriage never happened right support
would if you had kids but alimony it's
like you're not married so we didn't
have to deal with that
right clever right so that's a great
strategy to say look
if you want we'll go forward with this
he had
a humongous uh case against her built
did they have children not to my
knowledge okay yeah
anything in that article yeah he doesn't
have anything to do with her now if
there's no
connection there's no children and i
think the articles would have said there
was a child involved
so just a word to the wise uh if you
marry someone
don't sit on your hands if you think
that there's some reason why you could
the marriage could be voided or annulled
uh you want to take action because
you're not going to get sympathy from
the courts if you wait too long
you